lo que quiero hacer es otra especie de
demostración para calcular la suma de
una serie geométrica infinita y usaremos
una idea similar como cuando calculamos
la suma de una serie geométrica pero
finita así que digamos que yo quiero
calcular esta suma la suma y vamos a
empezar desde acá igual a cero hasta
infinito de
de nuestro término inicial que es a por
nuestra proporción común elevado a la k
muy bien esta es una serie geométrica
infinita y a este valor a este valor
vamos a llamarle s sub infinito muy bien
estamos calculando la suma para una
infinidad de términos muy bien entonces
esto quién es esto sí sí lo vamos
desarrollando pues será a por ere a la 0
muy bien sería por ere elevado a la 0
ahora qué pasa cuando k es igual a 1
tendremos a por r elevado a la 1 más
digamos a por r ahora elevado al
cuadrado y así podemos ir sumando todos
estos términos de forma consecutiva aquí
seguiría a por r al cubo más a por erre
a la cuarta y así sucesivamente hasta
infinito muy bien entonces aquí es en
donde vamos a utilizar una técnica
parecida al caso finito multiplicamos
ese infinito por r ok por nuestra
proporción común y eso fue lo que
hicimos en el caso finito verdad hacemos
r por s su infinito muy bien y esto que
nos da por por supuesto esto es una
especie de demostración cuando cuando
nosotros jugamos con el infinito hay que
hay que tener mucho cuidado hay que
pensar un poco más profundo porque
podemos estar haciendo cosas que no son
necesariamente válidas pero en este caso
si multiplicamos por r este término nos
queda
por ere elevado ahora la 1 más
más a por ere elevada al cuadrado al
cuadrado más a por ere a por ere elevado
al cubo y así sucesivamente verdad
estamos simplemente elevando a un
exponente mayor cada cada término de
esta suma muy bien entonces si nosotros
restamos
si nosotros restamos es decir si tenemos
ese infinito - r por ese infinito verdad
es decir restamos el de arriba con el de
abajo esto que nos da bueno pues lo que
tenemos que observar es que a poder real
a ceros sobreviven o se cancela y eso
simplemente es a pero ahora a por él a
la 1 se cancela con este de aquí a por
el real a dos se cancela con este de
aquí a por el real a tres se cancelará y
así sucesivamente todos estos se
cancelan hasta el infinito verdad todos
esos se van a cancelar ok entonces
simplemente nos quedó que esta
diferencia es igual a a muy bien sin
embargo lo que podemos hacer aquí es
factorizar ese infinito y si nosotros
factor izamos ese infinito nos queda ese
infinito que multiplica a uno
- cr y esto debe ser igual aa muy bien
entonces como nosotros realmente
queríamos calcular quién es ese infinito
entonces basta pasar dividiendo a 1 - r
ya que hay que tener cuidado verdad hay
que tener cuidado siempre vamos a
dejarlo en los mismos colores tendremos
ese infinito será igual a a a- entre
entre 1 - 0 y el cuidado que hay que
tener es que para poder dividir r no
puede ser uno no puede ser uno muy bien
entonces ahora ya tenemos el valor de la
suma de esta serie geométrica infinita y
esto es algo que a mí me parece
sorprendente es es increíble pensar como
una suma infinita de números puede dar
un resultado finito verdad y por
supuesto aquí como les decía hay que
tener mucho cuidado con con todas las
restricciones que estamos
o que el mismo problema nos impone muy
bien entonces vamos a ver un ejemplo
digamos que nuestro término iniciales 5
y nuestra proporción común r es tres
quintos entonces si multiplicamos cinco
por tres quintos nos queda simplemente
tres si multiplicamos por tres quintos
nos queda tres por tres son nueve y
dividido entre cinco si multiplicamos
por tres quintos nos quedan nueve por
tres son 27 entre 5 por 5 que son 25 si
volvemos a multiplicar por tres quintos
nos da 3 por 27 son 81 entre 125 que es
5 por 25 verdad y así podemos seguirnos
entonces esta es una serie geométrica
infinita y aquí nuestra proporción común
cumple que es más chica que 1 entonces
este resultado vamos a utilizarlo a es
nuestro término inicial que 5 entonces
esta serie geométrica vale 5
1 - la proporción común que son tres
quintos entonces esto simplemente será
esto será cinco entre uno menos tres
quintos son dos quintos y esto lo mismo
que cinco por cinco medios entonces son
25 medios esto es esto es exactamente
12.5 entonces esto es lo maravilloso de
las series geométricas como pueden dar
resultados finitos a partir de cosas
infinitas y recordemos que todo esto
funciona siempre y cuando nuestra
proporción común cumple que su valor
absoluto es menor que 1 ahora por qué
porque tiene que pasar esto porque cada
uno de estos términos tiene que irse
haciendo cada vez más y más chico porque
si se hacen muy grandes esto se va a
disparar hacia el infinito se hace muy
muy grande entonces necesitamos que el
valor absoluto de nuestra proporción
común sea más chico que uno
de hecho uno puede ver que ya hay
problemas cuando r es igual a 1 verdad
esta fórmula ya no tiene sentido porque
estaríamos dividiendo dividiendo entre 0
y eso no tiene sentido sin embargo si r
fuera uno tendríamos aquí a más a por
uno que es a más a por uno al cuadrado
que es a entonces estaríamos sumando
muchas muchas muchas muchas as muy bien
entonces si sumamos muchas hadas pues
esto claramente no no convergen se hace
un número cada vez más y más grande ok
sí por si por el contrario fuera menos
uno por ejemplo aquí tendríamos a menos
a más a menos a más a menos a y entonces
esto es un valor que bout oscilando y no
converge verdad va entre oscilando de
esta forma aunque entonces para er igual
a 1 y r igual a menos 1 no tiene sentido
así que sólo nos podemos quedar con las
proporciones comunes que tienen valor
absoluto menor que 1 lo que es lo mismo
esto esto es otra forma de decir esto es
que menos 1
es menor que r y es menor que 1 para
estos valores la serie geométrica se
converge